good news the war in ukraine is over
folks
zielinski has not repelled the russians
putin has not stopped the invasion
nothing like that has happened but
nancy pelosi has figured out how to end
the war
she does not have a peace plan to broker
and she has not managed to get those
polish fighter jets to the ukrainians or
or anything like that but
but she does have a poem written by bono
what you saw yesterday was history later
at the lunch just maybe you might want
to watch i'm going to be reading a poem
written by bono about ukraine which you
might find interesting
what's that president zelinski you you
want a global military effort to save
your country
yeah the best i'm going to be able to do
is a poem from bono and maybe you want
to watch i don't maybe just tune in i
don't know i think i read it pretty well
um
they say as we get older we become more
ourselves apparently this is the case
with nancy pelosi
this is like pelosi concentrate this is
the most
caricaturish
pelosi
experience i could possibly imagine
here's my answer to this global
potentially nuclear conflict i'm going
to read a poem
by bono and the poem did not disappoint
i got this message
this morning from bono
and most of us we're always whether
we're in ireland or here or whatever it
is avono has been a very irish part of
our lives
and he said
this he said
oh saint patrick
he drove out the snakes with his prayers
but that's not that's not all it takes
but the smoke symbolizes an evil that
arises and hides in your heart as it
breaks and the evil from risen from
friends from the darkness that lives in
some men but in sorrow and fear that's
when saints can appear
to drive out those old snakes once again
and they struggle for us to be free from
the psycho in this human family
ireland sorrow and pain is now the
ukraine
and st patrick's name is now zawinski
oh
okay on with our lunch that does it
right the war is over
take that putin
now of course ireland is not ukraine
they're very different countries
and zelensky is not a fifth century
roman christian missionary or a saint of
any kind that would require him to have
died and he isn't any of those things
anyway and bono's babbling and nancy
pelosi's babbling didn't do anything
other than make democrats feel better
about their disastrous policies that
triggered this war in the first place
there once was a man named joe biden
who when he first started president
gave into vlad's order for nordstream
the border of ukraine is quickly
subsiding
joe biden's strategic perversion
incentivized putin's excursion he
invited invasion of a sovereign nation
but only a minor incursion folks i could
be here all day and i promise you every
one of my poems will be better than
bono's and will more importantly be more
accurate than bonos this was such
it was a revolting display to see the
democrats
pretending that they're in any way
helping it's like that little meme of on
the simpsons i'm helping i'm i'm helping
by reading a poem by bono no you're not
you're not doing you caused the freaking
war in the first place because
your political party lifted the
sanctions off putin's nordstrom 2
pipeline this is what vladimir zielinski
the man you're calling a saint now he
actually said this is why the war
started and now you're making yourself
feel better by reading some
babbling nonsense
[Music]
you